hi i'm zoe deschanel and i'm gonna take
a buzzfeed quiz to see which character
from elf i
am
[Music]
first how would your friends describe
you
options are smart creative bold
nurturing sincere or ambitious
and the funny thing is like i feel like
now i would say creative
but when i was in high school i actually
had to do this
when i was doing college admissions
stuff i had to ask my friends three
words to describe me
and the word that came up with everybody
was actually ambitious
um but i would like to think it's
creative so i'm gonna say creative
choose a christmas craft to make with
your friends and family
paper snowflakes popsicle stick snowmen
crocheted ornaments hand painted
wrapping paper
diy wreaths watercolor christmas cards
i would say paper snowflakes because i
can make it with my cricut
and that would just be amazing my second
choice would be diy
wreaths but i'm going to say paper
snowflakes because they're really fast
and easy
now pick a holiday song to play on
repeat
all month long all i want for christmas
is you
by mariah carey fantastic song
santa tell me by ariana grande last
christmas by wham
mistletoe by justin bieber christmas
baby please come home by michael buble
or little say nick by the beach boys you
know what i'm gonna throw in
a curveball and say last christmas by
wham
because i just love that song it's so
good but i love all these songs i love
christmas music
i could play it all year pick a sweet
topping for your spaghetti
and i'm just gonna preface this with i
hate sweet things mixed with salty
things
i don't like it when people put sugar in
like spaghetti sauce i think that
feels really wrong to me so we'll start
with that but
my options are marshmallows m
ms maple syrup chocolate fudge
rainbow sprinkles or oreos i
love all of these this is very hard
i'm gonna say rainbow sprinkles just
because it reminds me of ice cream and i
love ice
finally choose something from the movie
elf the narwhal
i love santa's workshop
santa land baby it's cold outside
buddies
etch-a-sketch some of these things are
just a scene one's a kind of a character
one's a place
they're all great i'm gonna pick baby at
school outside just because i was
involved in this
it was so much fun to shoot with will
he's
such a wonderful person and i had a
really fun time making this movie so i'm
just going to pick that
oh my gosh i got buddy
like buddy you're creative enthusiastic
and
as sweet as can be you love to have fun
and are always down for a great time
you're pretty much ready for anything
you also care a lot about the people you
love and would do
anything just to make them happy listen
i love
buzzfeed quizzes and i actually do them
anytime they come up
so i guess that makes me also like buddy
so you guys
got my personality to a t thank you guys
for joining me while i did this awesome
buzzfeed quiz
this holiday season i will be making
stuff with my cricut
and if you have one you never have to
hand cut anything again and you can make
crazy awesome things like this happy all
the holidays thanks guys
you